oh there i'm karen wharton with film
courage the radio show i'm here at the
LA Film Festival with poorly rotate and
we've had a wonderful question come in
with our dear friend sherry Kaler and
she asks why did you start the film
collaborative i worked in distribution
for 12 years at done hard sales and
acquisitions and the entire time i was
working in a sort of normal overall way
i felt a little bit grossed out by the
extra layers of middlemen and I
constantly try to work on behalf of the
filmmakers even as an executive you know
helping to do better deals but the extra
layers of fat really upset me and then I
started a boutique consultancy company
called new American vision 2004 and we
treated filmmakers in the sort of very I
think they'll make a friendly manner
where we did take their rights and we
just did these deals and for very low
fees and I thought well why not just
make it official let's make it a
non-profit so the film collaborative is
the first nonprofit devoted to the
distribution of health and the way we
work and it's all on our website the
film collaborator or in terms of how we
work but we're an educational
organization first and foremost we it's
our mission to aggregate all the
information available about distribution
and marketing of films
and then to also be a service provider
in a very transparent and low fee manner
in which we don't take your rights so we
do play the role of bruce's rep to poor
sales agent or even direct distributor
in terms of aggregating films but it's
really ones choices to how you want to
work with us who else you want to work
with a spine we want a filmmaker to
build their own brand will be their own
best platform connect up to us as we
build our brand our own platforms and
help them connect to all the importance
of distribution avenues and platforms in
the world and obviously lose revenue
generating revenue generating was as
well and just sort of best maximizing
nervous the film's releasing potential
and so we're not profit we also do we do
work with more problems in other words
we're a smaller organization and we
don't want to be burdened by fundraising
to manage our own existence so I'm not
going to sit there in summary so we can
have a staff fifty guilty whatever we
can do with our you know limited staff a
handful of people and we have a portable
buzzers and a board of directors that we
rely on these are top heavy weight
nationals that's great music
yeah perfect segue would you know I
never words to their spot that we do
enhance and this will lock that we refer
to other people that we work with but
with those references or trusted service
providers where we vetted their services
we better the deals we're overseeing
relationship overseeing the deal we're
getting the discount we even have legal
services for flat fee of five dollars
and those are with you know a really
really excellent at parsing out rights
and helping you split your rights and
not get screwed over and distribution
deal and then we have for law firms that
back of our legal services so it's
getting lads I don't know how much of
our should say but I think that sort of
covers you know a lot of every to
grassroots marketing the actual
distribution hybrid theatrical
non-theatrical all that stuff
I just